Ngoài 2,5 tấm năm 2018, bị bán nhân dân xả hữu yệ, khoảng 7,7, trên địa bản vừa sẽ giá của ám à.
Thông tin bản đầu, khoảng 2,5 bà mì phút hồn qua, anh hát BT, xin năm 2018, chú thôn KHH, xả hữu yệ,
đi từ xá cá lộ về nhà thị gặp bốn đối tượng dừng bên đường tại khu vực ná ba của lộ chiến, đường đến thường khác.
Tại đây, anh Tây dừng sẽ họa chuyện, sau đó hai bên lời qua tiếng lại,
thơ đến nay, một trong bốn đối tượng trên đã dùng xung bán thằng vào vùng bụ của anh Tây dồi bỏ chốn.
Mặc dùng người dân đưa đi cấp kêu kỳ thời, nhưng sau biết thường quán nạc anh Tây không qua khỏi.
Ngay khi nhận tiến báo, công an xả hữu vệ bảo cao công an tình với hợp với các lực lượng liên quan hình chương trí sẽ,
khoa sắp mình, đối tượng hộ ngọt vê, sinh năm 2070 bệ chú tại bản chua, xa hữu ra,
là người trực tiếp nổ súng, đồng thời, các quan trích năng cũng làm việc với hộ quan đe,
sinh năm 2070 tắm, chú tại bản chua và hai đối tượng khác để làm só vụ vực.
Đường biết anh Tây có vừa vào con nhỏ hai tuổi, khoan cảnh sẽ đi khó khăn.
Đi phương đã đến tham hoa, đúng viên gia đình nạn nhân.